le but de la vie ouais carrément oui ben
autant aborder les problèmes
frontalement et le but de la vie c'est
une question qu'on s'est tous déjà posée
alors face à cette question la question
du but de la vie on a l'habitude de
proposer deux types de réponses
la première réponse consiste à dire que
la vie n'a pas de but
elle n'a pas de but parce qu'elle n'a
pas de sens en tout cas pas de sens en
soi du fait que la vie serait dû au
hasard
selon cette idée la vie serait une
propriété accidentelle de la matière une
propriété accidentelle de la nature ça
signifie que la vie a émergé sur la
terre et que finalement ça aurait très
bien pu ne pas arriver mais c'est arrivé
il ne faut pas y voir quelque chose
d'extraordinaire nous concevons la vie
comme quelque chose d'extraordinaire du
simple fait que nous sommes vivants et
ce serait juste la marque de notre
égocentrisme de considérer que la vie
aurait une quelconque valeur au regard
du cosmos et de l'univers la vie serait
une génération spontanée elle serait
apparue par la combinaison de facteurs
matériels qui reste en grande partie
pour nous énigmatique puisque c'est une
interrogation autant physique que
métaphysique mais une deuxième réponse
consiste à dire que la vie aurait un but
donc qu'elle aurait un sens c'est ce
qu'on appelle une conception finalistes
la vie aurait une finalité et dans ce
cadre on on présuppose que la nature
aurait été conçu pour accueillir la vie
c'est donc une pensée qui suppose un
créateur ou du moins pour éviter tout
risque d'anthropomorphisme une
intelligence créatrice
voilà les deux manière habituelle de
répondre à la question du sens de la vie
mais en fait cette présentation n'est
pas tout à fait exact car même si la vie
est un phénomène spontané
même si la vie est le résultat du hasard
on propriété accidentelle de la matière
elle peut néanmoins avoir un but un but
qu'on peut d'ailleurs observer ce but ce
serait tout simplement de se perpétuer
de se perpétuer dans le temps de se
propager dans l'espace à travers deux
modalités que nous connaissons bien la
conservation et la reproduction
alors d'abord la conservation la
concerne
son correspond chez l'animal à ce qu'on
appelle habituellement l'instinct de
survie mais on peut l'étendre au delà au
delà du règne animal
on peut l'étendre aux règnes végétal
voir minérale c'est ce que spinoza avait
appelé la tendance à persévérer dans
l'être et nous autres êtres humains
comme tous les animaux d'ailleurs pour
ceux conservés dans la vie nous avons
besoin de nous nourrir et de fuir le
danger c'est donc ça qu'on appelle
l'instinct de survie
et d'ailleurs nous cherchons tellement à
nous conserver dans la vie que cet
instinct de survie peut parfois décupler
nos forces
en cas de danger dans des situations
hostiles
nous sommes capables de déployer une
puissance insoupçonnée
dès lors qu'il s'agit de survivre
j'avais lu il ya quelques années
l'exemple de cette mère dont l'enfant
était coincé sous une voiture et qui
avait réussi à soulever la voiture
suffisamment pour en extraire son enfant
ce qui serait une assez belle
illustration finalement de cette force
de la vie qui cherchent à se conserver
envers et contre tout l'autre modalités
de perpétuation de la vie c'est la
reproduction la reproduction qui est
gouverné chez les animaux et chez les
humains donc par l'instinct sexuel et
pour qui a conscience de la force de la
sexualité dans notre vie on se dit que
la nature fait bien les choses puisque
elle a trouvé le moyen de nous pousser à
nous reproduire en nous procurant le
plus haut des plaisirs pour reprendre
vocabulaire de schopenhauer on pourrait
dire qu'il s'agit là d'une bonne
stratégie de la nature puisque la nature
a compris que pour nous faire survivre
il fallait nous donner l'envié de
survivre
or la reproduction est bien le seul
moyen pour l'humanité en tant que
collectivité de se perpétuer dans le
temps donc voilà ce que serait le but de
la vie se perpétue et se perpétue à
travers la conservation à travers la
reproduction
mais il est possible que cette réponse
ne vous paraissent pas très
satisfaisante
à vrai dire c'est une réponse qui n'en
est pas vraiment une
c'est comme de dire que dans une
équation x est égal à x c'est vrai mais
ça ne nous avance pas beaucoup et par
ailleurs si cette réponse n'est pas
satisfaisante
c'est tout simplement parce qu'elle nous
met face à l'absurde
elle ne répond pas à la question du sens
[Musique]
peut-être avez-vous le souvenir de la
réaction vous avez eu lorsque vous avez
appris lorsque vous avez compris que la
vie se finissait inéluctablement par la
mort le visage de l'enfant qui comprend
que tout être est voué à la mort c'est
le visage de l'incompréhension radical
c'est le visage de l'absurde
parce qu'après tout à quoi bon vivre une
vie qui n'ouvre sur rien d'autre
derrière
quel est le sens de cette vie qui serait
est indéfiniment sans qu'il n'y ait rien
derrière sans qu'il n'y ait de finalité
supérieur c'est en ça que la réponse du
but de la vie comme perpétuation
d'elle-même n'est pas satisfaisante pour
la conscience et c'est pourtant malgré
tout la seule et unique réponse que l'on
puisse apporter
qu'est ce qu'ils font
se pose la question du but de la vie et
donc par extension du sens de la vie
la réponse est très simple c'est le fait
que nous ayons une conscience
contrairement à la machine
nous nous posons la question du sens de
notre existence pouvait faire
l'expérience
vous êtes en train d'écouter vous avez
donc un appareil qui vous permet de
m'écouter que ce soit un ordinateur un
smartphone ou une tablette
regardez cet objet regardez le
attentivement et et posez vous la
question est ce que cet objet a
conscience de son rôle dans l'existence
est ce que votre téléphone a conscience
que grâce à lui vous pouvez m'écouter la
machine n'a pas conscience d'exister
elle n'a pas conscience de soi
je ne m'attarderai pas sur la question
de la conscience animale
c'est une question complexe tout ce
qu'on peut dire c'est que si les animaux
ont la conscience de soi et allons plus
loin s'ils ont la conscience du sens de
leur existence
la possibilité de se poser la question
du sens de leur existence
le fait est que il ne le manifeste pas
de manière visible
nous n'avons rien actuellement qui nous
permettent d'affirmer l'existence d'une
telle conscience de soi et d'une telle
conscience de l'existence
mais peu importe le fait est que nous
autres êtres humains nous sommes
capables de dire et de nous dire je suis
mais aussi de nous dire j'étais et je
serai là conscient
est indissociable du rapport au temps
d'autant plus que notre existence est
limitée dans le temps
c'est ce qu'on appelle la finitude nous
avons conscience de notre mort prochaine
nous avons conscience de notre condition
de mortel c'est ce qui faisait dire
heidegger lorsqu'il parlait de l'homme
que l'homme ne se contentait pas de
vivre mais qu'il existait et heidegger
faisait bien la distinction entre vivre
et exister une fleur vie une vache vie
mais un homme existe il existe parce
qu'il a cette capacité à se projeter
dans le temps qui lui permet de prendre
conscience de sa destination qui est la
mort voilà pourquoi heidegger avait
forgé le concept d'être vers la mort je
vous passerai le mot allemand pour
caractériser la condition de l'homme
c'est la base de ce qu'on appelle
l'existentialisme le fait que l'homme
n'est pas seulement un être vivant
l'homme est un être existants il est
conscient de vivre et d'aller vers la
mort donc la caisse
but de la vie disons plutôt du but de
l'existence
elle est directement liée à notre
condition d'être vers la mort c'est à
dire être conscient de devoir mourir un
jour
c'est très important de comprendre que
cette conscience n'est pas seulement une
représentation abstraite une
représentation intellectuelle de la mort
c'est à partir d'un certain âge
en tout cas à savoir profond ce qu'on
pourrait appeler une conscience
physiologique de la mort et finalement
si nous sommes bien ces êtres vers la
mort que décrit heidegger c'est à dire
des êtres conscients de leur condition
de mortel bien peut-être que le but de
la vie c'est d'accepter la mort ces
deux-là comprendre comme une nécessité
et donc d'y consentir montaigne disait
philosopher c'est apprendre à mourir
epicure disait que la mort n'était rien
la mort n'est rien pour epicure parce
que souvenez vous tant que nous sommes
en vie la mort n'est pas là en tout cas
il n'est pas là comme une réalité elle
peut être la commune une pensée une
projection mentale mais tant que nous
sommes en vie la mort n'est pas là et
puis lorsque la mort arrive nous ne
sommes plus là nous ne sommes plus là
pour en souffrir
si bien que la mort nous la croisons
mais nous ne la rencontre ont pas nous
n'avons pas directement affaire à elle
la mort n'est rien la mort n'est rien
c'est peut-être le meilleur moyen
d'évacuer le problème de la mort au sens
où ça résout totalement la question de
l' angoisse et dans ce cas peut-être que
le but de la vie comme le suggère
montagne ce serait de trouver la paix
malgré la menace de la mort qui plane au
dessus de nos têtes alors c'est très
difficile comme projet trouver la paix
c'est très difficile combien de minutes
par jour sommes-nous réellement en paix
on a toujours un truc qui nous tracasse
l'inquiétude
un agacement une agitation de l'âme il
faut pas oublier que étymologiquement
l'émotion c'est un mouvement un
mouvement intérieur un mouvement de
l'âme donc trouver la paix est peut-être
ce qu'il ya de plus difficile mais c'est
peut-être la clé est finalement
on trouve cette paix si tant est qu'on y
arrive bien la question du sens de la
vie ne se pose plus en tout cas elle se
pose plus dans les mêmes termes
quand on trouve la paix la question du
sens de la vie se dissout et la plus de
sens parce qu'alors le sens de la vie ça
devient simplement d'être est ce que
vous vous posez la question du sens de
votre vie lorsque vous êtes profondément
heureux vous pouvez mettre ce que vous
voulez derrière le concept de bonheur
ce n'est pas le problème mais imaginez
simplement passer un bon moment avec vos
amis au restaurant à la plage autour
d'un une partie de cartes
vous êtes en train de rire vous êtes en
train de ne penser à rien comme on dit
votre mental est vide c'est précisément
parce que vous êtes heureux à ce moment
là que votre mental évident parce que
vous n'avez besoin de rien pour vous
combler et à ce moment là si on vous
posait la question quel est le but de la
vie bien il ya de fortes chances pour
que votre réponse ce soir
c'est ça le but de la vie c'est d'être
heureux c'est la trempette alors oui
c'est facile c'est facile de dire ça et
je n'ai pas le mode d'emploi
mais j'aimerais vous soumettre un point
de vue j'aimerais vous proposer un
scénario imaginé que l'existence soit un
stage d'apprentissage en un mot bien sûr
un stage
tissage et qui seraient nos formateurs
nos formateurs se seraient nos
expériences nos expériences sont notre
principale source d'enseignements ce
sont nos expériences qui nous donne le
sont les plus utiles les plus fiables
je prendre un exemple à prendre
l'exemple de l'amitié alors qu'est-ce
que l'amitié bien dans la petite enfance
l'amitié démarre avec le jeu le jeu avec
l'autre trouve un un compagnon de jeu
et puis ensuite on va on va développer
une affinité avec ce compagnon de jeu on
va développer une affinité qui va ouvrir
sur des échanges
on va se prêter des choses entre amis va
se prêter notre jouet préféré en disant
fais bien attention de ne pas l'abîmer
et puis un peu plus
avant quand on va entrer dans le début
de l'adolescence on va faire d'autres
types des changes
on va échanger des confidences par
exemple ce sont des échanges immatériel
on va changer des confidences et puis on
va échanger de l'aide
c'est comme ça que se nouent une amitié
par le renforcement des échanges ou et
puis un jour peut-être va arriver un
conflit une dispute une trahison peu
importe
et puis ben si on tient vraiment à cet
ami qu'on a envie de renouer les liens
avec lui on va passer par la case du
pardon donc de la réconciliation
et c'est une amitié c'est quelque chose
qui évolue et la conception de l'amitié
qu'on a lorsqu'on a 40 ans n'est sans
doute pas la même que celle qu'on a à
quatre ans parce qu'entre temps on aura
fait l'expérience de l'amitié sous
toutes ses facettes
on n'aura plus une vision naïve une
vision purement idyllique on aura une
vision réaliste et globale c'est ça
finalement
notre meilleur enseignement sur l'amitié
c'est notre expérience de l'amitié et
non pas la définition qu'on peut en lire
dans un dictionnaire ou sur wikipédia
quand on voit des adolescents de 15 ou
16 ans s'envoyer des messages d'amitié
sur instagram ou sur ce match at on peut
pas s'empêcher de penser que dans
quelques années ils n'auront pas la même
conception de l'amitié ils ont une
vision sans doute et peut-être
malheureusement beaucoup moins naïve
cet exemple de l'apprentissage de ce
qu'est l'amitié évidemment il fonctionne
avec tous dans tous les domaines on
pourrait parler de l'amour la vision
qu'on a de l'amour lorsqu'on a 14 ans ne
correspond sans doute pas la vision
qu'on a de l'amour à 70 ans
parce qu'entre temps les expériences
qu'on a pu avoir de l'amour nous ont
montré que c'était quelque chose de
protéiforme qu'on ne pouvait pas réduire
prenons encore un exemple prenons
l'exemple de la colère la colère est une
émotion que nous connaissons tous à des
degrés variables mais enfin on sait ce
que c'est que d'être en colère et on
sait également quelles sont les
conséquences de la manifestation de
notre colère bien souvent il nous arrive
de regretter nous accès de colère pas
forcément que cette colère étaient
injustifiées mais on se dit parfois que
ça n'en valait pas la peine on a
peut-être blessé des gens pour rien ce
n'était pas nécessaire au bout d'un
certain nombre d'expériences
on va peut-être même commencer à se dire
qu'il faut qu'on travaille sur soi qu'il
faut qu'on fasse quelque chose pour que
cette colère ne soit plus une nuisance
dans nos relations aux autres
on va évoluer on va faire
l'apprentissage de l'apaisement ou pas
mais en tout cas nos expériences auront
été là pour nous signifier quelque chose
pour nous indiquer un chemin libre à
nous ensuite de suivre ce chemin ou pas
pour apprendre aussi l'exemple du
mensonge
il y a des gens dont le mensonge est une
sorte de mode de fonctionnement naturel
et qui sort demain pas compte à quel
point ça peut être pénalisant dans leurs
relations
mais au bout d'un moment lorsque vous
passez votre temps à mentir aux autres
et que les autres ne vous font plus
confiance qui vous tourne le dos à ce
moment là
comprenez que vous auriez peut-être
intérêt à faire l'expérience de
l'authenticité de la sincérité de la
franchise il n'y a pas un petit prof
avec une baguette qui va venir vous dire
il faut être franc il faut être sincère
où il ne faut pas se mettre en colère
c'est vous seul qui pouvait en tirer la
conclusion c'est vous seul
grâce à votre expérience et grâce au
retour de votre expérience
si nous sommes attentifs à nos
expériences et aux conséquences de nos
actes la vie nous informent elles nous
envoient des messages en permanence on
entend des fois
personne se plaindre qu'ils disent ma
vie c'est de la merde
ma vie c'est de la merde une fois j'ai
entendu cette phrase un endroit où je
travaillais et une de mes collègues a
répondu à cette personne avec une espèce
de franchise déconcertante mais tu sais
on a la vie qu'on se construit et cette
phrase je l'ait retenue comme une leçon
c'est le cas de le dire comme une vérité
absolue
on a la vie qu'on se construit c'est une
leçon de responsabilité et le mot
responsabilité est intéressant de ce
point de vue là parce que le réel c'est
ce qui répond à nos actes et nous mêmes
nous devons répondre de nos actes
l'apprenti
je sais cet échange continu entre nous
et le réel et le réel
c'est le seul juge c'est le seul arbitre
on peut pas pour
contre leur elle peut pas intenter un
procès aurait elle donc on ne peut pas
s'en plaindre
le réel c'est ce qui est le réel c'est
le résultat de notre comportement de nos
actes de nos pensées je sais que
entendre les choses comme ça parce qu'il
ya des injustices des injustices atroce
il ya des choses qu'on ne mérite pas
elle nous arrive mais il faut bien
tinue et à vivre et malheureusement
insulté la vie ne la rendra pas plus
supportable prendre conscience que tout
ce qu'on fait un impact sur la réalité
sur notre monde donc sur notre vie c'est
le vrai début de l'apprentissage
parce que c'est à ce moment là on prend
conscience de notre pouvoir d'influencer
le monde
le stoïcisme nous apprend que nous
n'avons pas à nous préoccuper de ce qui
ne dépend pas de nous précisément parce
que ça ne dépend pas de nous l'étatisme
nous dit nous ne devons pas être affligé
par la mort de nos amis la mort de nos
proches
parce que la mort fait partie de la vie
parce que la mort est inévitable et que
contester l'inévitable ne peut pas nous
rendre heureux
ça ne peut que nous rendre malheureux là
encore ce sont des paroles qui peuvent
paraître dur à entendre
mais c'est la vérité nous n'avons pas
p2 ce qui ne dépend pas de nous tout
simplement parce que nous devons nous
préoccuper absolument de ce qui dépend
de nous car seul ce qui dépend de nous
dépend de nous
c'est une tautologie mais c'est la
première leçon maintenant appliquons ça
aux émotions
on a commencé à le faire un petit peu
tout à l'heure lorsqu'on parlait de la
colère et imaginons toujours dans notre
petit scénario que nous autres êtres
humains nous soyons ici pour apprendre à
comprendre l'émotion pour s'en libérer
si nous étions des êtres entièrement
rationnelle nous n'aurions pas à faire
cette expérience
cet apprentissage ce stage de formation
qu'est la vie mais le fait est que nous
sommes des êtres d'émotion et que les
émotions peuvent s'expliquer au sens où
comme tout ce qui existe dans le monde
matériel
elles ont une cause ont réagi par
l'émotion lorsque l'on se sent atteint
dans sa personne qu'est-ce-qui
hadji qui s'exprime sous la forme d'une
émotion ses lego et lego c'est cette
carapace intérieur qui nous permet de
nous défendre contre les agressions
quand on vit en société on est en mode
ego 24 heures sur 24
on est sur le qui vive on est dans la
méfiance
on est dans la jalousie dans l'aigreur
dans l'anticipation le mental la peur et
c'est normal parce qu'on doit survivre
quand je dis que c'est normal
tout dépend parce qu'en réalité toutes
ces émotions qui nous gouvernent au jour
le jour
elle ne nous aident pas elles peuvent
éventuellement nous prévenir
elles sont des signaux des indicateurs
mais elle ne nous aide pas éprouver du
stress parce qu'on va passer un examen
par exemple on va passer un oral devant
un jury c'est normal c'est une réaction
d'autodéfense
mais le stress ne va pas nous aider à
faire une meilleure performance
on est bien d'accord on le sait bien sûr
et ça ne se contrôle pas on ne décide
pas de stresser pour le plaisir
c'est ça le propre de l'émotion c'est
qu'on a choisis pas mes notre ex
rien ne peut nous rendre attentifs à
notre émotion aux raisons de notre
émotion pour finalement nous aider à
l'accepter et ensuite à nous en libérer
on a besoin
souffrir pour cesser de souffrir on a
besoin de passer par l'émotion pour se
libérer de l'émotion et c'est quand
l'émotion nous a fait tant souffrir
qu'on ne veut plus les prouver qu'on
estime qu'on n'a plus besoin de les
prouver qu'on s'en libère la vie est un
stage de formation
et comme tout stage 2
sion si on ne valide pas nos compétences
on recommence
et on recommence aussi longtemps qu'il
faudra pour valider nos compétences
alors bien sûr ça
zéro mais qu'est ce que c'est que cette
vision mystico religieuse ou
philosophique
peu importe je ne suis pas là pour me
poser la question de la manière dont
sera interprété ce que je dis je lance
des bouteilles c'est mon boulot et la
bouteille que jenson aujourd'hui c'est
c'est cette bouteille du questionnement
sur le sens de l'existence ou en tout
cas le sens que l'on peut donner à
l'existence et ça me permettra de
boucler la boucle en revenant au point
de départ en introduction de cette vidéo
j'ai parlé du sens de la vie en disant
que pour certains la vie n'a pas de sens
donc elle n'a pas de but pour d'autres
au contraire la vie à un but prédéfinis
finalement une troisième voie est
possible
c'est la question du sens que l'on donne
à notre existence est bien la vie quoi
qu'on en dise est une occasion
d'apprendre et c'est une eau
lyon d'apprendre à se libérer de nos
émotions afin peut-être de trouver la
paix de trouver la sérénité qui nous
permettra comme le disait montaigne
d'accepter la mort la philosophie c'est
apprendre à mourir
le but de la vie c'est d'accepter la
mort et lorsque l'on est prêt à mourir
lorsque l'on a accepté la mort alors on
a bien vécu
merci à tous de m'avoir écouté
n'hésitez pas à partager cette vidéo
merci pour votre soutien sur tipi
n'hésitez pas à me rejoindre sur les
réseaux sociaux
je vous dis à très bientôt et d'ici là
soyez sages
[Musique]
oh